- I am now delighted
to introduce our speaker Daniel Alvarenga.
Daniel is a Salvadorian
American journalist
based in Washington, DC.
Is a writer for Telemundo's
English language new show, Radar2020.
He formerly worked as a producer for AJ+,
a digital channel by Al Jazeera.
He regularly reports on
politics, social movements,
and climate justice in Central America
and the United States.
He's the son of refugees
who fled the civil war
in El Salvador in the 1980s.
He studied linguistics at
the University of California,
Santa Barbara for undergrad
and received a Masters
in Corporate Communications
from IE University in Madrid.
I cannot tell you how special it is for me
to personally present Daniel to you.
For many years I did not
see the stories of my family
as Salvadorian refugees of
people from Central America
then yells work seeks to
unapologetically center,
the voices histories,
and experiences for people of the isthmus,
and I am personally thankful to him
that my nieces and nephew
won't have to experience
the relation that so many
of us have experienced.
With that, please help me
welcome Daniel Alvarenga.
- Hi, thank you everyone,
I'm Daniel Alvarenga
here from Washington DC.
I'm originally from the
L.A metropolitan area
which is home to the largest amount
of Central American diaspora
outside of El Salvador.
And I'm in DC where it has
like the highest per capita,
It's the biggest immigrant group.
And yes, I'm a journalist like
I was introduced by Eileen.
I originally, when I signed on to this,
I was still working Al Jazeera AJ+,
I spent the last three years there.
So much of this talk is gonna
be focus on my work there
but I'm also now with
Telemundo for a new show.
And I'll talk about that
a little bit at the end,
but I'm kind of we're
gonna walk you through
some of the stories that I've worked on.
Some of the themes that I touch,
some of my favorite stories
and what's shaped my storytelling
and my analysis on Central Americans
in the U.S and globally.
And like Eileen said, part of
the reason I got into this,
was because I was
frustrated at the coverage.
I was a student journalist
like 10 years ago
then I couldn't get a job at the industry.
And then I just started
tweeting into the void
and started writing and started blogging
and then sort of built a
journalism career starting 2014
with the migrant crisis
that happened that year
that centered Central Americans.
Before we get into it, I need to talk
about who are Central Americans.
Who are Central Americans?
Central America is seven countries.
It is multiethnic, multiracial,
and it's not just Mestizo in European,
it's home to a lot of indigenous folks,
it's home to Afro indigenous folks.
They don't just speak Spanish, I'm there,
parts speak English and
believes in certain coasts,
Creole languages and a lot
of indigenous languages.
It's a mega diverse region and it's hard
to really encapsulate it, I think,
but I'll try to make sort of footnotes
on the other Central American countries
but my reporting is gonna focus mostly
on the top three right here,
Northern top three, Guatemala,
Honduras, El Salvador.
And I'll get into sort of why that is.
And that's sort of been the
bulk of my work as well,
those three countries.
So here we have a look at the
Central American population
from 1980 - 2015, this is from a piece
about how U.S involvement
in Central America
led to the border crisis.
It's by AJ+, I helped
produce it, is on YouTube.
Basically there wasn't a whole
lot of us compared to today.
In 1980, there was like
less than a million.
Now there's over three
million in three decades.
And what happened in
1980 to now, civil war,
neoliberal economic policies
in the post-war period
of El Salvador gang violence,
a ton of U.S intervention.
And this is a population
for all of Central Americans
in the U.S but it's
largely made up of people
from the Northern Triangle
and the Northern Triangle,
I never really questioned
that term before.
When I came into college,
it was already being used.
I just thought it was like
sort of a formal place,
a formal way we referred to this place.
But what was the Northern Triangle?
The Northern Triangle was actually,
it started off as not really meaning much
in terms of nobody's to
say Northern Triangle
in the nineties, in the eighties,
but it was a commercial designation.
It was a commercial designation
and it usually represents free trade,
neoliberal policies in the region.
So it started in 1982,
it gained popularity
with the free trade agreement, Mexico,
and it's, okay, it sounds
harmless if you think
neoliberal policies are having this,
but it sounds harmless
this sort of designation,
but it's sort of taken on a different life
since this commercial designation.
So now the Northern
Triangle is just synonymous
with death, violence.
Here are a couple of
headlines, I'll translate them
for those who don't speak Spanish,
Spanish section of the Chicago Tribune
called it, "The Northern Triangle,
"What Are The Most Violent
Zones In The World?"
El Mundo called it,
"The Triangle Of Death,
The Invisible Routes Of Refugees."
And then, Sky News has it, if
you can't read it's too small,
"Northern Triangle, The
Vicious Gave War Being Fought
Over Every Street."
And then this sort of
hopeful one from 2018,
"The Northern Triangle Is
Becoming Less Murderous."
But the implication
is that the Northern
Triangle was murderous.
And it's through this lens
that I came to know the Northern Triangle.
I think most of us know
the Northern Triangle,
it came from a commercial designation
and it became this narrative.
The Northern Triangle
is also the countries
that are coming here the most.
As you can see, this is data
from the Pew Research Center.
You can find that at the
Pew Research website,
going into the Trump administration
the last years of the Obama years,
you saw a ton of migration
Northern Triangle
to the point where like
the Northern Triangle
sort of lumped in with itself,
here and kind of counted as one entity
and it started out pacing immigration
from Mexico, which has historically been,
one of the more constant
immigration waves in the country.
And around 2014, you
started to see a shift.
As a Salvador, I always constantly grew up
meeting people coming from El Salvador,
they're coming through L.A,
they're gonna go to
their next destination.
L.A was so close to the border
relatively than here in Washington DC,
and I don't remember a time growing up.
I was born in 1989, the
tailoring of the war.
I don't recall a time where
people weren't coming to the U.S
from El Salvador, and
that's also can be said
for Guatemala and Honduras as well.
If anything, the more recent
waves are heavily favored
Honduras and Guatemala versus El Salvador.
We'll get into some of that.
So then this happened
in the summer of 2018.
I was a year into my job at Al-Jazeera.
I didn't really produce news videos.
I wasn't creating a whole lot for them.
I was a freelancer but I was
sort of updating their Twitter.
And so I would go through
all the breaking news
all the time and I was
constantly pitching stories
about Central America, it's like,
we need to talk about Central America.
And everyone thought
like, okay yeah, Daniel,
you're from there, it's a niche for you.
You're passionate about it.
We hear you, but there's
not a whole lot of audience
for the elections in Honduras
for what's going on in El Salvador.
And then this happens,
reports started coming out in mid 2018
that 200 children were
separated at the border,
at the U.S Mexican border.
Around 2000 miners were
separated from their family.
And we're still seeing some
of this play out today.
They're still like, they couldn't find 500
of these unifications, like 500 of them
are still pending and they
can't find the parents.
Some of these were younger
than three years old.
It captivated the country,
these headlines were everywhere
and these images were everywhere.
I was becoming a journalist at this point.
And I was showing all of
my clips to my family.
All of my family is, I'm the
only one who's not a refugee.
My siblings are refugees
from the civil war.
My parents were refugees
So I always share my stories with them.
And I think at this
point is when I started
just not sharing them as much
as being a little bit more selective
because it was overwhelming for all of us
to just be bombarded with this news.
And it wasn't new to them,
they were listening to it
on the TV as well but I'll never forget
that moment in the newsroom that it took
the theft of thousands of
children from Central America
for me to start giving editorial opinions
because I was kind of the only expert
in the newsroom at the
time that really understood
intimately Central America
and had a connection to it.
So I started taking on
a lot of these stories
and there was also the ProPublica thing
was also another like watershed
moment around the same time,
same year when the children
were separated at the border,
And there was recording,
that was like the evidence, the proof,
and that was broke by ProPublica.
And we did a video with some of the audio,
the border agent goes, where are you from,
the child says El Salvador and you,
another child says Guatemala
and then you hear a
cacophony of children crying.
And this also captivated the nation.
And I was just kinda like,
whoa, maybe people are
finally starting to listen
to Central Americans or tune in
to Central American politics and issues.
But one thing I've learned in news
and just living life
that the attention span
for the news cycle for
anything really is only so big,
and for Central Americans,
the amnesia is pretty bad.
So these images, we all saw these images
plastered everywhere two years ago.
I know it's not interactive
but I'm gonna give you a second to guess
what year do you think this is from.
Since this is the stock image
that you see with every story.
So when I'm looking at a story
up on Reuters, Associated
Press, I see this all the time.
And these are kind of the images
that a lot of articles
will use a stock images
for their articles.
But they are not from
the Trump administration.
These images though, I'm
sure they're still relevant
to what's going on,
they're not from the Trump administration.
They're actually from 2014.
It got so bad in 2018 that
the AP had to fact check
with its own photos.
They are being used to accuse
the Trump government of,
being used as proof of Trump's policies.
When in fact, they're actually the truth
of the Obama era policy
that builds upon the legacy
of George W. Bush and Reagan and Clinton.
So I always want to impart
that sort of this immigration
moment that we were in, wasn't
just brought about by Trump,
It's been a bipartisan strategy for years.
Yeah, and these images still get used.
They're still pretty relevant
to a lot of the news going on,
and there's not a lot of stock
images from ICE facilities.
So I don't blame journalists
for having to use this
because there's not a whole lot for us to,
there's not a lot of people
going inside of these attentions
all the time or you get like
these doctored PR photos often,
especially in the last year or two.
2019 I started seeing a lot
more propaganda style photos.
But it just shows that we
just have such an amnesia
with Central American immigration
and sort of the U.S has
relation to that region
because just six years ago,
the 2014 Central American
unaccompanied minor crisis
when 70,000 unaccompanied
minors came to the border,
these kids, they were like
kinda young to like teens,
some of these kids,
they're not kids anymore.
This is six years ago.
They're in college classes.
They message me on
Twitter asking me things.
They're part of the population
here in the U.S now,
and we've forgotten about them,
And we forgot this happened in 2018.
And I would say 2014 was like
my journalism origin story,
because I was so heated at the fact
that a lot of people are
like, how did this happen?
How did we get here?
And knowing me, I never remember
a period where Salvadorans
didn't come here all the time
and by extension other Central Americans.
So to me it was very weird
that we were acting 2014
like this was a new thing.
And then again, in 2018, we
acted like it was a new thing.
And so I always push
people in the organizations
that I'm a part of, to
really think a little deeper
about the U.S relationship
with Central America.
It's only like two or
three countries away.
I know Mexico is massive
but there was another media moment.
There was several media moments
and one of them, and
there were several deaths
on the border that had
happened around this point.
But I think what really galvanized
people was that children
were dying on the border in ICE custody.
We have different ones here
since fourth, fifth, sixth.
There was, I think up to seven children.
There's been probably hundreds of adults
that have died in ICE custody
since the agency was open in 2013,
you're gonna look at the
records, it's not just Trump,
It's not even just the Obama era,
though a lot of it ramped up
in these last administrations.
So these children were dying,
and again, it was like, Whoa
America is starting to listen.
U.S is starting to listen.
They became symbols,
Jakelin Caal, Felipe Alonzo.
So Jakelin Caal, this image here
is by visual artists on brooms.
And this image was in so many
protests across the country.
So many people printed it out.
I saw it at protest against ICE.
These children have become a symbol.
Here is Zoe Saldana sharing Felipe Alonzo,
Another one of the children
who died of neglect
at the border, and then
Don Cheadle's photo,
Don Cheadle the Hollywood actor,
his Twitter photo to this
day is still Jakelin Caal,
Indigenous Maya girl who
was killed at the border
or died of neglect,
however you wanna say it.
But Jakelin Caal's name
kind of was like that to me.
'Cause I know the region, it didn't sound
like a Hispanic last name,
it sounded like perhaps
a MileIQ last name,
so I did the story with
the international MileIQ
about these children,
and this is a quote from Juanita Lopez
of the international
MileIQ, and I read it out.
"You hear about immigrant children
"dying at the border, but you don't hear
"that these are indigenous
children dying at the border."
And this is from a
video I did last October
for Indigenous Peoples'
Day where we explored,
why are the majority of the children
dying at the border are indigenous?
Why aren't we asking this question?
The headlines buried a lot.
These are the indigenous
Guatemalan children
that have passed away at the border.
And there's another child
that died after them,
or like died during the same
period but was reported later.
It was a Salvadoran girl.
I don't think she was indigenous,
but these children weren't
just indigenous Maya.
They belong to different Maya nations.
Claudia was Maya Mam,
Jakelin was Maya Q'echi,
Felipe was Chuj, Juan was Maya Ch'orti,
Wilmer was Ch'orti as well.
And Carlos was Achi and so I
never saw too much dwelling
on their identity as indigenous peoples.
They were called migrant children,
at best they were called
indigenous Guatemalan children
but they were mostly just called
Guatemala migrant
children in the headlines.
And I felt that that was
leaving a lot out of the story.
And so then I looked up what
about the indigenous identity
of these children if formed
why they had to migrate?
And if you look at the numbers
of inequality in Guatemala,
the malnutrition rate
is high across the whole country.
It's even higher up to 70%
in more heavily indigenous
populated areas.
79% of the indigenous people
in Guatemala live in poverty,
40% in extreme poverty.
So what you're seeing here is,
indigenous Guatemalans facing
more institutional neglect
than non-indigenous Guatemalans
and then you sort of start connecting,
so like they're also the
ones disproportionately dying
at the border, as well as in Guatemala.
And they're also being
displaced from ancestral lands
by palm oil plantations as
was the case of Jakelin Caal.
There's also the issue
of language injustice.
These are the languages,
officially recognizing
languages in Guatemala.
There may be more, these are just the ones
that the government recognizes.
The vast majority of
them are Maya languages.
One is Garífuna another
one I think is Xinca
that are not Maya,
but these are the indigenous
languages of Guatemala.
There's like 22 to 23 of them,
depending on what count you use.
And this was a huge part of the story.
And eventually people
started reporting on this,
but I remember when it was breaking
I was just kind of like, do
we know where she's from?
Do we know if it's from an indigenous area
and for Jakelin Caal's story,
this had a lot to do with it.
In fact, three Maya
languages, not just one,
three mile languages,
Mopan, K'che and Q'anjob'al,
are some of the most used languages
in immigration court in the top 25.
The problem is there is not
enough interpreters and so,
they're probably not getting
the same kind of attention
articulating their migration
and getting the same kind
of attention that Spanish speakers get.
And statistics say that
speaking indigenous language
means that you'll likelier
to be denied medical care.
People who speak Spanish or English,
already get denied medical care
but there's this another layer
with people who speak indigenous languages
that they're not listened
to, and a lot of the children
who died in ICE custody were indigenous,
may have spoken indigenous language
or they were imprisoned with,
as in Jakelin Caal's case,
father who spoke his native language
which is a Mayan language
and didn't receive
the same kind of attention.
Since people may not have understood.
And the language barrier that has to do
with their identity is huge.
It's a huge part of their story.
It's a huge part of why they're leaving.
What the moment first
place not even to say
why they're more likely
to die in ICE custody.
And then there was more deaths.
There was more deaths.
This is the one that really shook me.
This really shook me because
there were Salvadoran
and it was a death of Oscar
Alberto Martinez Ramirez
and his daughter by Valeria,
I'm not gonna show the photo.
I think a lot of us remember the photo,
they were trying to get
to Brownsville, Texas,
I think over the Rio
Grande and they drowned.
On that Rio Grande I'm not quite sure
but they drowned in a
river and their dead bodies
were on display on every network.
This started such a heated newsroom debate
or whether should we show it?
Should anyone show it just
because CNN is doing it?
Should we do it?
And that photo again, captivated everyone.
There was a ton of art about it
but a lot of people don't
remember who these people were.
We can make a lot of assumptions
that people are fleeing El Salvador
in this case because of violence.
It has this image of violence,
the gangs, homicide, rape,
often one of the most dangerous
countries in the world.
I think people already
sort of have a narrative
as to why people are leaving El Salvador.
And poverty is one of them, but I feel
that poverty in the case of Oscar Martinez
was a bigger factor than violence.
He worked at Papa John's,
he made $350 a month.
Between him and his partner,
they couldn't really make ends meet
and that was their motivation to migrate.
We talk a lot about the
military intervention
in this country, but so
much of the intervention
is sort of invisible and it's economic.
It's not just soldiers.
It's not just arms,
it's not just security.
What is the economy like in El Salvador
that is making people
like Oscar Martinez flee.
Here's just a little snapshot
of the economy in El Salvador
incredibly neoliberalised post to war.
Remember the Northern Triangle started off
as a economic zone sort of.
And this was a region
that was very much
economically affected by war
and made her vulnerable
for free trade to come in
and rebuild the region.
And it went very extreme with this.
Post-war we had 20 years of a right wing
sort of oligarchy running things
and they never really
stopped running things
but we had 10 years of leftist FMLN.
And so we had neoliberal
reforms that privatized
telecommunications, banks, electricity,
and what this did was it made the cost
of especially electricity
and telecommunications
double or triple for the population,
and the economies dollarized.
That's something that
it's very understated.
It's about El Salvador has been
a dollar economy since 2001.
And so it has increasingly
made the country
economically harder to live in.
So what has made what Guatemala,
Honduras and El Salvador so
unlivable before migrants.
Sorry, I was looking at a comment.
So lemme see.
I think it's very much a very
big narrative that gangs.
I'm not gonna dwell on gangs.
I feel that often when I'm
asked to talk about El Salvador
or I'm invited to the table
or the editorial table
in the past, was because
Trump says something
about MS-13, he calls him bed on brace.
He calls him animals, and
now we have to respond to it.
And we have to talk about it.
Long story short, MS-13
was born in the USA
and it has become our
prevailing image of ourselves.
And there's so much
behind the gang at play
that works against people
trying to make a life
in Central America, trying to
survive in Central America.
One of those huge elephants in the room
is U.S intervention in Central America.
And you can't talk about the gang problem
without U.S intervention Central America
because a lot of those kids
were more refugees for one.
A lot of those people
came here fleeing war
and then came into Ronald Reagan's America
with no safety net and
then got mass deported
in the nineties under the
Clinton administration,
once they went harder on immigration.
The U.S involvement in Central
America goes very far back.
Here's a moment from February, 2019,
where representative Ilhan
Omar, grilled Elliott Abrams
on the Trump's Envoy Venezuela.
Elliot Abrams oversaw a
lot of what was going on
in El Salvador at the time.
And so she used his history
to make a case against him
not involved in Venezuela.
And so, in that hearing she says,
"In that hearing you dismissed
"as communist propaganda report
about the massacre El Mozote
"in which 800 civilians
"were brutally murdered by U.S troops.
"That including children
as young as two years old."
El Mozote is the biggest scar
of the Salvadoran civil war.
My family who fled in the early eighties
doesn't really know a lot about it.
It still evokes a lot of
(speaks in foreign language),
a lot of just like feelings
for Salvadoran diaspora
because we haven't really
seen a whole lot of justice.
A whole village was scorched earth tactic,
just disappeared, burned,
children murdered, women murdered.
I went to El Mozote 10 years ago
and 20 or 30 years after the
massacre, there's still blood
on some of the bricks
that make the new church.
Because original one was
breakdown with people inside.
And so Ilhan Omar somehow broke through
the usual U.S amnesia of Central America.
And wouldn't straight come to the juggler
and not only grilled Elliott
Abrams on, it's on a blog also
about the Ixil indigenous Maya massacre
that happening with Guatemala
and the country war in Nicaragua.
And interest Googling El
Mozote hit a historical high.
It measures it here from one to a hundred,
but a hundred means just like the peak
of what that term has been searched.
And that happened in February, 2019.
And it was a big deal.
It brought back into the
collective consciousness
of the U.S a rare moment that like,
hey, Central American
refugees is not a problem
that started with a Trump administration.
Here's a snapshot of
some of the U.S military
involvement in the region
by far not exhausted
but for the countries
that we're talking about,
some of the most significant
were the Salvadoran civil war
was 75,000 people died 85%,
and this is according
to the truth commission,
85% of the acts of violence
committed by the U.S backed
or committed by U.S backseat agents,
that is the death squad.
The Salvadoran military,
it was backed by the U.S
started with actually Carter
and then Reagan blew up
these military budgets
and made it this deadly
thing that happened.
And Guatemala's war was longer.
What was this 12 years from 1919
to what Guatemala's was from 1966 to 1996,
200,000 died, 93% of human violations.
Almost all of them were
committed by U.S backseat agents
and Guatemala's civil war
had the characteristic
of being a very over indigenous genocide
where maybe had trials.
Guatemala's actually had trials
and sought justice against war criminal.
Something that it's still lagging on
like 30 and 40 years later.
And then in 2009, that
was sorry, that's my cat.
In 2009, there was a U.S backed coup
in Honduras that destabilized the country.
It's why you see so many migrants
from Honduras to this day.
And this is just a snapshot.
Like we're not even talking
about the other Central American countries
like the Panama invasion in 1989 and '90.
Nicaragua's wars, sometimes I like to call
the eighties just the
Central American Wars,
because there was a stage in El Salvador,
stage Guatemala, stage in Nicaragua
and then Honduras was also militarizing
not technically at war, but with us.
And the Hunduran military
committed massacre
in Salvador and chaos in
Sumpul killed hundreds.
And they were hostile to
refugees from the other countries
and we're militarizing as well.
And I often include, one to
talk about Central America,
I often call it just the
Central American Wars
kind of like how a lot of
people talk about Vietnam
and has different stages
in different countries.
But Central America is not super unique.
U.S military interventions,
Latin America go as far back
as the Monroe doctrine
like a hundred years ago.
And as you can see from 1980 to now,
these populations have just increased.
Salvadorans being the largest
Central American group in the U.S.
I focus on these three
countries, but displacement
of Central Americans
affects the whole region.
Here's an article from Billy's.
The neighboring countries end up
having to absorb a lot of this.
It doesn't just affect our countries.
Billy's will have refugee communities.
Mexico has almost a
hundred thousand refugees
in the suburbs, refugees
and asylum seekers.
There's around 500,000
refugees and asylum seekers
from the Northern Triangle,
300,000 are internally displaced
and addressable suburb.
The displacement doesn't happen
when they leave the country often,
displacement usually
happens internally first.
And this was true when my parents fled.
Their villages got too dangerous.
So they only went to the Capitol.
And then from the Capitol,
they went to the U.S.
Internal displacement is a huge problem
in the Northern Triangle specifically
and Nicaraguans are also have sought
international protection last year.
A lot of them, a lot of the migration
can make it also involves Costa Rica.
Costa Rica is a big country
that receives a big number
of refugees as well.
So the narrative of Central America
is also beyond Central America and U.S
having just this like
really toxic relationship,
it's also like Northern Triangle and U.S
having this talks to reach,
but it also involves Mexico,
heavily involves Mexico.
And it involves the
other countries as well.
Here's a something just
to show the more invisible
interventions that people
may not know about.
It's not as overt.
One is the DR-CAFTA which
was a free trade agreement,
similar to NAFTA, and it
basically gave multinationals
the influence over domestic trade.
And in countries like El
Salvador and Guatemala
that we're recovering from war.
A lot of their infrastructure
was shaped by these policies.
There's a special case also
that I found from Salvador
where the U.S threatened
to withhold 300 million
in millennium challenge
corporation development aid
because El Salvadoran farmers were wanting
to use native seeds and not Monsanto.
So this was basically a paid incentive
to use Monsanto seeds
which are more expensive.
You have to renew them.
They don't, how do I say it?
With native seeds you can
just keep growing generation
of corn after generation of corn.
For example, from these Monsanto seeds
like you have to buy the seeds every
time you're gonna plant them.
You can't just grow
your own from the corn.
It's this weird Frankenstein
experiment that they're doing
with the people, with Salvador.
But I got this from the community.
It's all already from people at Salvador
that works on a ton of
environmental issues in the region.
Another thing that's
making Central America
a livable climate change.
3.9 million climate refugees
in Central America and Mexico
predicted in the next 30 years.
Central America is dry quarter.
It's going through droughts.
This is especially true in Salvador,
which has the least amount net resources
because of its size, but
basically the dry quarter
is where a lot of crops are.
Because of the effects in climate change
and not just climate change
but agribusiness in the region
like palm oil plantations
and sugarcane plantations,
display scene where people
would just grow their food
for them to eat as well as
climate change has resulted
in this perfect storm for
environmental crisis seas.
This region is also prone to hurricanes,
prone to earthquakes prone to volcanoes.
El Salvador has incredible
water scarcity problem.
Here is a climate activist,
a water activist in Salvador
who talks about how unequal,
unjust water scarcity
is affecting the lives of
daily, rural Salvadorians.
The debate over a Salvador
over privatizing water.
They privatize everything else
because it's a neoliberal economy.
So now they're like, oh, how about water
and water is already
becoming inaccessible.
And some might argue
is very privatized now.
If you don't have a faucet,
which a lot of rural Salvadorians don't,
you ended up paying almost $4 for a glass
or for a jug of water
when your daily pay is $6, for example.
This is the way that economic policies
and economic principles,
neoliberal principles
imported from the U.S make it hard
for everyday Salvadorans to live.
Central America is also a region
that is incredibly hostile
for people trying to protect
these master resources
especially to Honduras that has been named
one of the most dangerous countries
for environmental assistance in 2017,
a year after Berta Cáceres
Lenca, indigenous activists
was shot and killed in her
home for opposing a dam.
And this photo is more recent,
Las vidas garífunas también importan.
Garifuna is an Afro
indigenous group in Honduras
for other land defenders had gone missing
because the Honduran government
wants but resorts there
and multinationals and under government
prefer to have resorts there,
than let Garifuna people
live on their ancestral land.
And I think I'm a little bit over time,
but this one to conclude what
these words by Nana Teresa.
Nana Teresa as a Maya Mam,
elder with the Mayan League
and I encourage you all to
check out the Mayan League
but she said this, "The
governments aren't our governments,
"they're the governments of the rich,
"the big businessmen, landowners."
And that encapsulates a
lot of Central America.
And a lot of what's making
it unlivable right now
beyond the violence, beyond the headlines.
And this is also coming from perspective
from an indigenous woman
who is a war refugee
and has had to leave ancestral lands.
That concludes kind of what I had to say.
I think around the 12:40
mark was just stop,
but if you wanna learn more,
I encourage you to follow me.
These are more Instagram handles
but even more so than
encouraging to follow me.
I want you all to watch and
subscribe to my new show.
It is by Telemundo, it's
an English language.
It's new and it's not
your well less Telemundo.
And that's where you're gonna see
a lot of my reporting in the future.
I wanted to turn it over
to perhaps the moderator.
- Yes, Thank you Daniel and
we do have a few questions
so we're gonna try to get
through as many as we can.
So up first we have
Hector Peralta who says,
"Can you perhaps talk more
about the politics of language
"within headlines, I'm
particularly interested
"in the potential way
that Northern Triangle
"parallels the language
of Banana Republics?"
- Yeah, the Northern
Triangle is not a name
that we gave ourselves.
We already don't really have any
self autonomy in our determination.
We were given these names by a businessman
who wanted to create an economic zone
and now those economic policies result
in so much social unrest and violence
that it become a shorthand
for those violent countries.
So, yeah, I do think it
has that connotation now.
Maybe a nice way of saying
we'd been under Republic.
I definitely agree.
And I had been called out on unconsciously
promoting the Northern Triangle name,
but it also just, the country conditions
had been shaped so much
by economic policies
that it's hard to extract
the Northern Triangle label.
This is why I want more
Central Americans to create
and write about ourselves
and come up with new ways
of naming our region.
I don't know if that answers your question
or was I supposed to type that?
- No, Hector let us know if
that answered your question
but up next, we have Cindy Santana
who is a Salvadoran American
documentary filmmaker
and storyteller as well.
Their question is, "How do you ensure,
"what are some of the actions
that you take to ensure
"that you're honoring the people
"and their stories when
sharing their image,
"voice, et cetera, or more generally
"how would you say you
practice ethical storytelling
"through your journalism work?"
- I think one thing is consent
and having that consent be very active
and very thoroughly explained.
I re-work on the story
but I've seen stories
where people will do a story
on MS-13 and Buddhists.
And the people said, yeah sure.
Use my face it's fine, and
then they weren't reached
onto like oh, this is gonna go on YouTube.
This is gonna be global,
everyone can watch the link,
It's not just gonna be a little broadcast
in a foreign country that
people are gonna see.
So I think it's just informing
people as much as possible
about how you're gonna use
your voice and for what,
what audiences are they being exposed to,
and brainstorm some of the
issues beforehand research,
what are some of the issues
someone can run into.
So with the case that
we'll do that, it's like,
okay, so this story goes
out and they have heartedly
didn't understand what the agreed to.
Let's say they send a release
form in a different language.
And it wasn't explained to them,
'cause even if the
release form is in Spanish
like if I'm interviewing
folks who don't have access
to the sort of type of language
they're using contracts,
I need to explain that.
So it's sitting there
and informing the person
that is gonna bring your story alive.
They're doing you a favor,
so you also have to make sure
you're not gonna burn that bridge
and not gonna burn them in any kinda way.
So Buddhists case, it turns
out that we had to pull a piece
because they're like,
faces needed to be blurred.
They didn't understand how
exposed they were gonna be.
And so then, we took a
video down because of that,
and having those conversations
and not skimping on those,
is how you kinda practice it.
- Yeah, thank you.
Up next, we have Sadler
Sanchez who is thanking you
for all that you do.
Towards the beginning you mentioned
how you became more
particular about what stories
you shared with your family
as they became heavier.
They're wondering how you ground yourself
amid all of that heaviness.
- Yeah, in community honestly.
I think the reason I do what I do
is because I created a community to cope
with the Central American Twitter,
where I got a lot of my
following as early journalist,
and my family also
helps ground me as well,
they're part of my storytelling.
Part of the reason I like to
involve them in my storytelling
and it's kinda like, hey,
I'm working on the story,
what do you think from your perspective?
I wanna tell the story about the war
but I have these facts, does
it line up with what you saw?
Does it or not, and we
have a discussion about it.
And sometimes those things
are too heavy to get into,
because it can be very triggering
for folks in our community
and even just sharing news
and expecting my community to share it,
I know I'm exposing them to trauma.
I think mental health resources,
I'm lucky that as a full-time journalist
that I have access to
mental health resources
and every newsroom should be
'cause of the vicarious trauma.
But on top of that being Central American,
I think there is a lot
of work around trauma
that we need to do.
I encourage the reading of Martin-Baro,
I think it's called
"Liberation Psychology"
which specifically
addresses our war trauma.
That informs a lot of our other traumas.
Mental health and friends, yeah.
- I have a follow up question to that,
growing up in a similar way
I very much recognize now
that I grew up in both the
culture of trauma and silence.
Just not knowing why the
heaviness was in the room
or why things were the way they were.
Partly because the stories
weren't being told,
how do you get to that place
to even ask the questions
of your family members?
What is your story?
- All right, I've been very
blessed to have interviewed
two Holocaust survivors in my life.
And they've informed how,
the U.S doesn't have a good
framework to talk about war
and trauma often like the world war II
and the Holocaust is often the most
I think we talk about fascism
and its effects on people.
And so I drew a lot as a young person
from that and in interviewing
Holocaust survivors
as both a young person in my community,
but also as a journalist,
one person told me that for
a lot of Holocaust survivors,
their parents are two types.
And I'm not comparing
the Salvadoran civil war
to Holocaust, but an atrocity right?
Some parents are completely silenced.
They wanna forget, they wanna
move on because of the trauma.
And some parents never
stopped talking about it.
They never wanna forget, so the overshare,
they may be overshare too much.
They may not have access to therapy.
So maybe they're telling
the family stories
as the only thing they can
and I was clearly part of that group.
Where I was hearing war
stories at like eight or nine
and being like I had to, my mom telling me
that she had to identify her
her brother in a mass grave
'cause he was in gallia
and he was killed by the death squads.
And so I was exposed to
these stories early on
and I feel like it's blessing
in disguise because yes,
it's a lot of burdens on
trauma but I was also given
the tools to be able to tell
these stories, to seek them out
and to have these
uncomfortable conversations.
And for my parents that
had given me clarity
my parents migrated in their
late twenties, early thirties.
So around my age so they were
also very mentally astute
as to what was going on around them.
They saw their society
crumble around them.
So I was very lucky that I
had parents who were open.
But if you don't, I say, learn about it.
And once your parents find that,
'cause this is what I also did,
once I did parents saw that
I was learning about it,
that I was trying to
understand the reality.
They also opened up even more.
That's been my journey with that.
- Yeah, I don't remember
when but I remember seeing
your Twitter and you sharing
something about like,
oh, Salvi parents, will
just casually throw out
or trauma and definitely in a really sick
and funny way felt rang true to me.
So speaking about Twitter and media,
we're gonna go to Emily Arman's question,
who says, "Thank you for your
top notch Twitter content
"and your journalism."
As a Central American scholar,
she can't express how much it
has helped her own research
and organizing work.
"I'm wondering if you can
talk a bit about how the media
"that sometimes tries to
lend sympathy towards those,
"this place from Central
America often infantilizes
"the individuals being targeted
"by state violence early children.
"How can journalism academia
organization dissolve the idea
"that an individual community
is deserving of rights,
"respect, often retroactive human decency
"and garner public support
for their agency and migration
"without labeling unwavering innocence
"and passive victim hood
as a means of doing so?"
- Wow, that's a good question.
That's something that I'm trying to figure
out myself as well.
I'm constantly tasked
with having to humanize
Central Americans in a way that people
in a news organization or people online
may not be familiar with and
I think part of that is just
seeking out Central American
voices to speak for themselves
and also getting Central
American journalism
and professionals who can speak to it,
not just professionals but
also have them in the mix too,
because as much as it's about
getting the right people in the voices.
You're not gonna get those people
unless you are part of their community,
unless you're interacting with them.
So partially is also getting
Central Americans in the room
not just Salvador, is not just Mistasis,
not just white Central
Americans, but getting people
who know how to talk about this community
who can go beyond the pass the
victimhood and the innocence
and tell fuller pictures.
I think it's kinda two-prong,
It's getting the person
to ask the right questions
to journalists and finding the people,
and basically opening
pathways to black indigenous
and journalists of color in the newsroom.
I benefited so much from Al Jazeera
being a middle Eastern focused newsroom
with a lot of people of
color in the newsroom.
And they talked about issues of war
and all that stuff often,
so I don't know what it's like being
in an all white
institution and doing this.
That's part of the
reason I went to Twitter
to yell about it.
I think if these institutions,
academia, organizing whatever
aren't doing it for you
then create your own path
yelling into the void,
find people to have
this conversation with,
because it's also a conversation
that Central Americans
we should just be having
in the media and public.
It's something that we should
be having with ourselves,
that people got community.
But yeah, that's a difficult question.
I don't feel like I answered it too well
but it's something that
I still struggle with.
- I got a message separately from Emily
saying that that was a
great answer, so thank you.
As my follow-up to that,
about a year or two ago,
we had a different
pointer fellow journalist
who was American with no relational ties
to the Central American region.
Award-winning journalist in their coverage
of gang life and some--
And you mentioned earlier
how these are often
how we're depicted.
So it's either we're
victims or we're criminals.
Why is responsible reporting specifically
for journalists that are
looking into the area
from an outsider gaze?
- Can you repeat that last sentence?
- What responsibilities do journalists
have that are reporting in the region
that are looking at it
from an outsider gaze?
- Very simple, listen to
Central Americans right.
That's been frustrating with me too
because these are people in the industry
that I've had to become
friends with and learn from.
And these are the sort of
the gatekeepers at ministry,
but it's this fine line of being
able to voice your critique
but also not upsetting the gatekeepers.
It sucks, it's in a lot of
industries, it's an academia.
I don't honestly concern
too much with those people
all the time, obviously I have
the write to their gaze often
and encounter that but
instead of putting my energy
into correcting every white
person, every white journo
who gets something wrong,
that's energy that I could be putting
into the Central American community
mentoring other journalists,
elevating the voices of people
who are talking about this
in an inappropriate way.
It's jarring, that's part of the reason
I came into this work.
I don't really know if I
would've been in journalism,
if it wasn't for 2014 and
me being just so pissed off
at how mainly white
journalists were covering,
like, oh my God, where did
they come from these migrants?
Why are they so violent?
And also like sometimes we
need to read these stuff
to keep up to date, but I think
just always being relentless
with the critical gaze and
don't be afraid to challenge
these folks who are gatekeepers
in media and industry,
don't feel free to challenge
me and people challenge me
about the Northern Triangle stuff.
Yeah.
- Thank you, and I wish we had
time for all the questions,
but one final one, I'm
gonna go to Jesselene Paz,
who also happens to be the president
of our Central Americans for Empowerment
student group at Yale.
She asked, "Do you have any advice
"for young Central Americans
who want to tell stories
"about Central America, but
not exclusively on trauma,
"but also joy, family,
community, et cetera?"
- Yes, write about those things,
create about those things.
You may not think there is
an audience for those things,
but there totally is.
When I think about an account that focuses
on a lot of like Central American joy
I would say there's account
called Central American Beauty
that just shows the beautiful
things of our isthmus,
the vegetation, the
diversity of its people,
the traditions, the richness of them too.
Tell those stories.
My only advice is to tell them
and who cares if people
don't want to hear them,
put them on your Instagram,
put them on Twitter,
put them on medium and
then people will come.
We don't need the validation so much.
I don't get the validation from
my peers and the journalism.
I get my validation from what my community
says about my story.
If they liked the story and reformed
their worldview about us,
then that for me is a win.
But I struggle, I wanna tell more stories
about the good things that
happen in Central America too.
I think the closest I got
to it was Palestinian Salvadorians.
I did a 10 minute history
explainer about that.
It's include war obviously,
but it was a lot more
about their cultural
traditions and just do it.
Don't wait for an opportunity.
- Thank you, and thank you Daniel,
this has been such a joy to have you here.
I wish that we had more than an hour.
I'm sure our audience members
have lots more to ask.
So please follow Daniel.
Could you quickly mention
again your Twitter handle or--
- If you search for me,
Daniel Alvarenga on Twitter
and Instagram, I don't know
the first thing that comes up
but my handle is, let
me write it in the chat.
Let's see if that'll be helpful.
My Twitter handle it's @_danalvarenga
and Instagram is @salvi_prince.
I've had that account for a while
and it's just become a thing,
it's not super professional
but it is what it is.
And don't forget to watch and subscribe
on Radar2020 if you wanna see more
of my stories in the future.
- Great, thank you and
to all those watching
please follow other Central
American journalists
and writers and scholars we're out here.
So representation definitely matters.
Finally, I wanna give a huge thanks
to Yale College alumni Alfred Caldwell
who organized all of this last year
but unfortunately we
couldn't make it happen
as the pandemic happened but here we are.
So thank you for your work and
labor of love for your peers.
And that's it.
Thank you all and have a
wonderful rest of your day.
- Thank you for having me.